avec bruno moynot thierry lhermitte
gérard jugnot avec également jean marie
proslier marie-anne chazel yves lecoq
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
josiane balasko yves duteil et didier
barbelivien
bonjour à tous bienvenue sur antenne 2
rendez-vous qui je l'espère tous rue
sera habituelle désormais chaque jour à
midi nice l'académie des neuf une
émission de jeu qui va permettre à deux
candidats chaque jour de s'opposer de
gagner de gagner quoi bien une monnaie
assez intéressante qui ne va pas
souffrir de l'érosion monétaire
ce sont des billets de à deux vous les
présente il y aura des billets de 10 à 2
et voici il y aura des billets de 100 à
2 et liant aussi des billets de mille à
2 ces billets permettront en fin de
semaine le vendredi aux candidats
gagnants de participer à une vente aux
enchères assez intéressante vente aux
enchères au cours de laquelle sera mise
en vente des téléviseurs des voyages une
voiture pourquoi pas un magnétoscope des
lots assez extraordinaire avant toute
chose si vous le permettez la
présentation des deux premiers candidats
de l'académie des neuf sous les
applaudissements de notre public ici je
voir votre prénom suivi et inscrit sur
votre corps saint jean pied de vous un
bonjour je m'appelle anne walker je suis
étudiante en droit et en troisième année
ils sont non je préfère pas encore oui
et j'habite farine et vous habitez paris
dans quel arrondissement de paris on va
tout savoir 8e en huitièmes je sais que
l'un des académiciens tout à l'heure à
demander votre numéro de téléphone
vous avez refusé catégoriquement de le
donner vous ne voulez toujours pas le
faire
à vos côtés au côté d'anne yves qui êtes
vous mêmes questions lalonde
oui je sais je travaille je suis
régisseur dans un théâtre à paris je
suis metteur en scène et danser oui oui
si toutefois vous avez des reproches à
faire la mise en scène de cette émission
je vous le signale à la fin il dit et
j'habite paris également bien alors deux
parisiens ce ne sera pas une habitude
d'un je tiens à vous prévenir parce que
j'espère que vous qui êtes chez vous à
lyon ou marseille tourcoing lille
roubaix
vous viendrez participer un de ces
prochains jours à l'académie des 9
le premier jeu le voici les neuf cases
[Musique]
alors l'objectif pour ce premier jeu
d'être simple il va s'agir pour vous en
choisissant à chaque fois un académicien
de tenter de tracer une ligne
horizontale verticale ou en diagonale et
vous disposerez d'une croix ce sera
votre signe distinctif c'est à dire que
nous verrons apparaître la croatie votre
académiciens la peau bien la question
quand avoue anne vous disposerez d'un
rond nous sommes bien d'accord
alors qui va commencer tirage au sort je
dispose d'une monnaie la vraie une pièce
de 5 francs à pile ou face ils pile hop
hop hop
elle n'est pas tombée ce qu'on a répété
total comme deux fois c'est pile c'est
donc vous anne qui commence et qu'elle
et l'académicien avec lequel vous
souhaitez jouer avec marie-anne chazel
avec marie-anne chazel bonjour noël
chazel vous ne parlerez peut-être du
père noël tout à l'heure on l'évoquera
oui je vous remercie de nous le
confirmer voici votre question
marie-anne chazel 1789
donc ça date pas d'hier dans quelle
tenue digne d'un joueur de poker
malchanceux se présenta à naouar pour
son mariage avec le major maurice job
vous disposez de 30 secondes top chrono
dans quelle tenue le jour de poker mal
si l'apa est là il a pas triché
c'est pas le tricheur non non je vous
donne la tenue simplement adapté tricher
mais enfin généralement c'est différent
parce qu'ils se chargent c'est dans
l'est qui lui qu'ils ont de la plume et
ils ont deux du bourg on le sait que
dans un mariage vous savez on ne triche
pas enfin pas moi je dirais quoi je
dirais par exemple un tonneau avec des
bretelles ou un truc comme ça donc
illégales il est arrivé habillé avec un
tonneau et les bretelles une seconde
s'est terminée dans cl je veux dire un
art ward
c'est ça oui mais il ou elle de toute
façon ce n'est pas ça elle est arrivée
je vous le dit entre nous tout nu dans
un caisson de bois
[Musique]
debise est demandé dans quelle tenue il
fallait simplement dire toute nue elle
était tout nu que vous ne l'êtes pas
vous ne marquez pas un share and de
petits ronds avoue yves il faut tenter
d'inscrire une ligne sur les neuf cartes
alors alors je le choisis jean-marie
proslier jean marie poli un jour dessus
polier monsieur premier le maire de la
commune devait les rats en suisse un
pays que vous connaissez bien pour le
visiter souvent vient de prendre une
décision inattendue est embarrassante
pour les autorités laquelle trente
secondes s'adjugeait de la chasse aux
escargots donc ce n'est absolument pas
la chasse aux escargots bien une
histoire comme ça des quelques années
puis c'est pas un maire qui a décidé de
le transformer la monnaie locale en
monnaie française jours comme ça vous
savez des suisses qui se transforme la
monnaie suisse en un mot les français
j'en connais pas beaucoup car se doit d
être suicidaire ça existait bien des
gens qui ont besoin de vie le suisse qui
va planquer son argent en france allait
pas ça du tout ça arrive ça arrive trois
secondes deux secondes
bah oui
merci beaucoup monsieur produits et
c'était très intéressant
le maire qu'est ce qu'il a fait je vous
donner la réponse
il a décidé de faire sécession de la
suisse et de proclamer l'indépendance de
son village son village compte 70
habitants pour être rattaché au jura il
a fait briller une érigé plutôt une
barrière douanière imprimer des
passeports donc il ya là maintenant un
pays qui s'appelle d'après lui un la
commune deux éléments très longtemps
après la naissance dans un à la peur
c'est à vous maintenant toujours
marie-anne chazel toujours marie-anne
chazel vous avez peut-être raison
marianne le théâtre olympique
vincenzo construite en 15 180 oui oui
permis pour la première fois les
spectateurs de regarder des spectacles
sans regarder le ciel pourquoi top
pourquoi tu vois pas le ciel c'est
qu'ils aient un toit
oui c'était donc un vélum ce qu'on
appelle vous savez une espèce de toiles
de tentes
ce théâtre et est donc le premier à te
ferme est exactement votre réponse
l'objectif est de tracer une ligne
d'euros ou de croix pour l'instant à nos
félicitations et c'est à vous de contrer
son directeur pour vous 10 à 2
les choisir yves lecoq vous choisissez
yves lecoq yves lecoq voici la question
rois du gag à rebrousse poil
alfred jarry fit un repas très
particulier lequel sera pas à quelque
chose de très original conneries
intérieur direct peut-être sur le
comptant de lentillac avos poil et
peut-être fait un repas dévorer ses
heures qui ne manque pas de sel il
attendait ce n'est pas ça s'éteint c'est
un vrai européen qu'il a fait mais il le
fait de façon très originale gens ne
souffle pas
walt attention deux secondes une seconde
il est bien entendu la réponse est la
suivante c'est que simplement alfred
jarry le papa du père ubu avale un repas
complet mais à l'envers c'est là qu'il a
commencé par les digestifs et ensuite il
a terminé par l'apéritif est paraît-il
son dernier désire avant de mourir fut
d'avoir un cure dent
il intègre oui donc pas de croix pour
vous nous avez toutes les chances 10 à 2
pour l'instant pour vous avec qui vous
voulez vous jouer des gars gérard jugnot
avec gérard jugnot une erreur noir
gérard jugnot
c'est à vous il a fini le repas non à ce
concert repas paris 7 ans fermes dans
une petite pièce c'est ça mais là je
crois que vous trompez de questions ça
c'était avant
les ulm ont envahi paris que veut dire
ce titre de journal
cet enfant tu as assez les ulm scellé
c'est les engins légers les ultimes
ultra légers dans les très casse gueule
là comment s'appellent les les ultra
léger motorisé ça wily pas leurs efforts
un deuxième rond c'est pas mal les ulm
ce sont les ultra léger motorisé des
trucs casse oui comme vous le disiez
tout à l'heure je crois et 20,2 pour
vous maintenant je crois yves qu' il
serait sage de jouer avec josiane
balasko avec josiane balasko pour
contrer votre adversaire josiane voici
la question et c'est déjà la sixième
question un jeu qui en comporte 10 que
rapportèrent à l'inventeur monsieur john
walker les allumettes qui prouvent
qu'ils n'ont su très bien dit john
[Rires]
qu'est ce qui leur rapporte beaucoup
d'argent
non la reconnaissance de la nation
non un titre de l'ordre de 20 degrés il
a beaucoup de chaleur il a perdu il a
perdu la vie non willis non j'ai rien
alors j'ai entendu un rien avant le
vôtre mais c'était peut-être un écho
prémonitoire c'était non d'airé personne
ne dit rien rien c'est la bonne réponse
en effet john walker l'inventeur des
allumettes n'a pas déposé son brevet et
sa fortune est peut-être parti en fumée
en tout cas essentielle ils n'en avaient
pas puisqu'il n'a rien touché après
cette invention ce qui est fort
regrettable alors on a vu que vous
n'avez pas pu établir votre ligne il
reste quelques questions il en reste car
ton poids de précis que choisissez vous
maintenant jean marie pauline jean marie
poli jean marie voici la question quel
genre très surprenant de serveurs
primates pouvait on trouver en egypte du
temps des pharaons 30 secondes des sages
n'ont message des singes et non
je crois qu'on présente oui vous pouvez
préciser peut-être par des prix bas tu
sais où un homme très gros ce qui est
très vulgaire au défunt sajoo 1 les murs
ya autre chose comme ça c'est la réponse
j'étais moi-même sûr qu'on est sympa
c'est il faut impérativement maintenant
jouables kid loco qu'on est d'accord
vive le coq c'est la huitième question
pourquoi yves lecoq 150000 parisiens
sont ils plus heureux depuis le mois
d'août
écoutez je ne sais pas il faut demander
au maire de paris et je pense pouvoir
être très clair en vous disant que j'ai
supprimé les welters pour empêcher
gaston defferre
peut-être que nous avons des couloirs
pour l'équipe est bonne réponse couloir
pour les cyclistes
a paris il reste encore deux questions
maintenant aussi la 9e alors que les six
dévoue avec qui voulez vous jouer avec
thierry dernier thierry conan identifia
ton très rapidement un automobiliste qui
percuta et endommagea un poteau
télégraphique à ontario au canada
il alla s'est accroché le poteau n'ont
pas permis de conduire à s'accrocher aux
poteaux c'est presque ça cesse sa plaque
d'immatriculation à s'accrocher aux
poteaux et vous vous n'en est pas loin
non à papier non lui même nom avec mort
avec son nom n'ont cessé mais sa femme
est à reste a conçu la voiture à
s'accrocher au nom du parti de la
voiture ou pas c'est ça que ça concerne
en effet une partie de votre parti n'a
pas sur le volant de la no
bon dynamisme et bien je vous donnais
traitement sa plaque minéralogique
[Applaudissements]
on attend des données
sa plaque minéralogique avait laissé
l'empreinte du numéro de la voiture et
oui vous n'avez pas dit fait chaud chez
nous vous ne m'avez pas donné la bonne
réponse je le regrette
nous allons voir où nous en sommes il
reste une seule question maintenant est
ce que nous avons la possibilité et
georges perrier va nous montrer les
quatre noms on n'a pas la possibilité de
faire une ligne de fer unis aucune
possibilité
aussi nous allons conclure concernant ce
jeu féliciter tout de même les candidats
qui disposent chacun d'une petite somme
déjà 30 à 2 pour anne et 20 à 2
maintenant pour notre ami yves nous
allons maintenant vous proposer le
deuxième jeu il s'agit du dernier des
neuf le dernier je vais voir une invitée
c'est josiane balasko pour qu'elle nous
parle un petit peu de ce père noël dit
moi entre nous c'est vraiment une ordure
n'ont eu le vrai perdrait non non nous
en fin de 6e quand même beaucoup
d'enfants qui nous regarde ne peut rien
sinon une charte rageante il donne des
cadeaux et tout mais le nôtre joué par
gérard jugnot dans le film père noël est
une ordure c'est vraiment une ordure qui
s'est passé cette nuit de noël a dû être
effroyable au départ savez la nuit de
noël ces quelques c'est une nuit qui
fait ça pour s'amuser se réconcilier de
joie de bonheur tout ça est l'aîné d'une
enfant tout ça et là ça va être la
catastrophe chez sos détresse amitié qui
est une piscine de secours norales par
téléphone qui danse
or ben yahia jugnot dont j'ai dit qu'ils
me l'ordre ça arrive et me regarder le
sait
il ya marie-anne chazel d'accord chacun
se connaît bien gérard ya marie-anne
chazel qui est la femme du père noël qui
ne venaient pas très avantagés
physiquement dans le film a des très
grandes dents elle a des problèmes
d'élocution les chars moquer un peu
enceintes rondes au sein de 13 ans aux
danses et nous avons bruno moynot qui
est un visiteur émigrés enfin disons un
ami un voisin immigrés qui va venir les
déranger toute la nuit pour leur faire
goûter un gâteau en forme de son pays et
est donc trois répondants et katia katia
j'oubliais katia qui est joué par
christian clavier qui merveilleuse
christian duval bord d'un magnifique
travesti ses traits d abba en compagnie
de l'ermite tirer d'anémone je suis une
personne qui est censé faire le bien et
on n'est pas très au point à 26 ans ont
tous dévoilé du film cette nuit de noël
se termine bien il ya quand même pas mal
de problèmes il laisse beaucoup de
péripéties ya énormément de péripéties à
une tragédie
on voit tout ça dans vos reer problème
parce qu'il faut bien rigoler un peu il
ya une grosse tragédie
il ya un mort bien enveloppé d'ailleurs
c'est le plus âgé à avoir le sind et
surtout nous allons maintenant à nouveau
jouer ensemble au dernier des neuf
nous allons poser des séries de
questions pour éliminer les académiciens
les uns après les autres
le dernier académiciens en course pour
gagner le candidat avec lequel il joue
il ya une prime de 100 à 2 à la clé ce
qui est tout de même important vous avez
ça aussi c'est important et je m'adresse
aux candidats la possibilité de refuser
la réponse de votre académiciens sais
pas si ça se voit mais il fait très
chaud
j'espère qu'il fait bon chez vous aussi
alors voulez-vous que nous commencions
c'est à qui c'est avoue yves vous
commencez avec josiane balasko
lequel des trois josiane une réponse
immédiate s'il vous plaît la boulie
qu'est ce que la boulie ab pollue elle a
eu un mot argotique pour proposer pour
offre un terme de jeu de boules un
manque de volonté
le premier le premier un mot argotique
pour offre vous êtes d'accord
je dirais un manque de volonté manque de
volonté c'est vous qui avez raison vous
marquer 10 points supplémentaires 10 m2
supplémentaires des impôts revoir
mademoiselle balasko n'est pas votre cas
il ya le fleming est il un savant qui
découvrit la pénicilline un coureur
automobile ou un auteur de romans
d'espionnage
c'est un savant qui a découverte une
seconde êtes vous d'accord
bien sûr bien sûr c'est un éclair qui a
succédé à philippe auguste au trône
aulas philippe iii le hardi louis 8 le
lyon ou robert 2 le pieux
dans paris c'est le boulevard voltaire
mais ça va être philippe trois ans rue
philippe iii leur dit yves daccord nous
il vous dit d'accord c'est faux c'est
faux c'est faux c'était louis 8 le lion
enfin ce n'est pas très très grave
au revoir monsieur barbelivien à merci à
plus tard monsieur mono s'il vous plaît
archi log désigne un bout de vêtements
complètement déchiré moisi bon à jeter
un peu être grecs de l'antiquité ou un
conférencier spécialisé dans les
discours sur l'architecturé l'urbanisme
une réponse irait
un conférencier spécialisé un
conférencier spécialisé tous d'accord
vous êtes d'accord c'est très bien c'est
un peu être grecque et qui se doit faire
énormément plaisir
un poète que tu est une antiquité avant
monsieur voie d'eau tiède ermite la
sonde us lancé sur mars
fut-ce marine air de pioneer 5 ou
vikings 2 le deuxième c'est à dire
pioneer st ouais
êtes vous d'accord vous êtes d'accord
très bien c'était vikings de bassam
habitants c'était avec amber en vendée
chez derbi
monsieur jugnot le droséra drosera je
vois votre visage je vois votre visage
qui s'éclaire est une plante carnivore
de l'asie l'amérique ou l'europe
c'est une plante puisqu'on utilise en
homéopathie mais je peux pas je rappelle
que le journal est à 12 heures 45
aujourd'hui dans l'attenté de réponses
on restera le temps qu'il faudra c'est
l'asie l'amérique ou l'europe
je dirais une réponse j'ai râlé l'europe
l'europe
êtes vous d'accord non vous n'êtes pas
d'accord il fallait la fin c'était bien
l'europe métier puisque gérard jugnot
que les plus parfaites nicollier combien
de hanau on a éteint monsieur jugnot
c'est une erreur à monsieur junior est
en notre compagnie monsieur proslier
combien de facteurs sont il mordu par an
en france
3000 facteurs 4200 facteurs au 4700
facteurs je parle des préposés à
demander combien que trois mille 3000
4200 et 4704 bill 204 1212
vous êtes d'accord il n'y en a que si je
puis m'exprimer ainsi que 3000 donc ce
n'est pas la bonne réponse
nous perdons pour l'instant monsieur
proslier marie-anne chazel de biens non
au oui parce que quand on était en net à
l'ombre il fait moins chaud
engoncé marianne oui c'est traiter une
porte ou une fenêtre s'est préparé un
vêtement ou c'est une façon de préparer
la volaille pour la cuisson
c'est quand on est serrés dans son
tonneau
non non c'est l'une des 3 % des
possibilités donc c'est traiter une
porte cachée après par un vêtement ou
préfèrent une volaille
je dirais le premier premier
c'est-à-dire la vie d'une traité une
porte une fenêtre puisqu'à des gants
vous dites qu'il faut c'est faux c'était
préparé un vêtement engoncé en vain
mariage est oui vous savez bien souvent
j'ai des problèmes d'élocution
mademoiselle chazel je voudrais bien me
pardonner
monsieur yves lecoq voici la question
il existe une mine d'or ouverte en
france s à 5 6 dans l'aude au châtelet
dans la creuse ou à la lucette dans la
meilleure c'est une bonne question
d'avoir son corps ne répondait c'est
lamine keita gauche là la première
question quoi alors celle-ci que chez
telus est
voilà la première alors répondait à des
questions monsieur arrêtez votre
question celle ci celle-ci qu
aujourd'hui la deuxième - vous dites la
deuxième c'était celle ci qui veut le
cac avait tout à fait raison
nous allons maintenant changer de jeu et
vous proposer des homophones des doubles
sens donc yves duteil c'est à vous
maintenant je prends un exemple si je
dis le cochon fumée et philosophe
anglais vous me répondez bacon bien
entendu 1
voici donc le premier homophones
employés de bureau ou oiseaux employés
de bureau oiseaux attention encore
quelques secondes une réponse ici le
canton c'était secrétaire voir yves
duteil merci duteil monsieur jugnot s'il
vous plaît monsieur jugnot s'il vous
plaît échassiers religieux musulmans
la réponse marabout êtes vous d'accord
d'accord c'est la bonne réponse marc à
bord il reste en course maintenant yves
lecoq yves attention et bien sûr gérard
jugnot et bien sûr cristal et jeux de
cartes cristal et jeux de cartes
il écope bakar un bac arts à aix et
n'entraient pas car oui excellente
réponse il fonce réponse c'est ce que je
dis c'est en effet une excellente
réponse gérard jugnot et yves lecoq
cannes c'est à vous maintenant gérard
jugnot rapaces villes d'italie
on ne souffle pas si on souffre on
souffle plus fort bilan êtes vous
d'accord sur ces 1000 ans est-ce qu'on
va arriver à vous dépasser le match
entre les 2 yves mammifères félin et
villes de france
il améliore beaucoup les bonnes réponses
ma réponse c'est la question est ce
qu'on va arriver à départager
monsieur jugnot est monsieur lecoq nous
allons savoir tout de suite un titre de
noblesse et un gigot de mouton monsieur
géniaux une réponse immédiate parce que
maintenant il va falloir conclure faire
de l'étude êtes vous d'accord
non non non monsieur jugnot non on
éteint votre 15 1 saint juniauds c'était
un baron un titre de noblesse un gigot
de mouton
yves lecoq et yves dernière question un
habitant de l'alaska une combinaison en
tricot inscrire mon nom ce qui m'aurait
dit d'accord ou pas vous êtes d'accord
vous gagnez yves lecoq est le dernier
des neuf
vous gagnez donc 100 à 2 supplémentaires
ne vous rendez compte maintenant ce qui
donne pour nos amis 160 à 2 pour yves ce
qui est pas mal 81 un léger retard ou et
vous vous êtes là 82 pour anne mais je
pense que c'est un retard qui sera est
rattrapé je vais demander à brigitte de
vous donner maintenant votre monnaie
c'est à dire les billets à 2 vous
pourrez vous en servir dans quelques
instants tout maintenant va se décider
lequel des deux candidats sera là demain
lequel l'emportera le maximum 2 à 2 pour
pouvoir en profiter lors de la vente aux
enchères de vendredi nous allons le
savoir dans quelques secondes
avec les neuf à la cote alors la règle
du jeu est tout simple avant l'émission
nous avons demandé au public
ceux qui parmi les académiciens avaient
le plus de chances de nous citer des
mots entièrement constituée
phonétiquement par des notes de la gamme
exemple la gamme vous la connaissez do
ré mi fa sol la si do exemple un petit
enfant fait dodo voici les cotes qui
viennent d'apparaître sur votre écran
donc le spécialiste de ce genre de jeu
d'après le public incontestablement
c'est didier barbelivien et quant aux
autres ça se partage à jean-marie
produit aussi alors c'est à qui tu jouer
maintenant s'il vous plaît c'est avoue
anne voulez-vous en sachant que vous
disposez de 80,2 que vous avez un léger
retard nous dire quelle est la somme que
vous misez et avec qui voici les cotes
une nouvelle fois alors combien date de
mise et vous vous en disposez de 80 jean
misez 40 ou là la matière et oui oui sur
sûr
jean-marie proslier sur jean-marie
premier 6 contre 1,40 à 2 x 6 nous
l'espérons alors jean marie voulez vous
me citer trois mots entièrement
constituée phonique phonétiquement par
des notes de la gamme trois mots si ray
ciré doré doré
il est resté pareil non il est resté
vannes va mieux
il
1000 à 10000 à la musique
admirez mire et miré mire et bien sûr un
adversaire philipp et désaveu
supplémentaire 40 à 2 x 6 puisque
c'était la cote le score va paraître
dans quelques instants
yves que faites vous la question voulez
vous connaître la question qui était
posée au public
je suis la donne bien volontiers la
question était la suivante vous qui
parmi les académiciens le plus apte à
nous citer cinq artistes ou écrivains
français qui se sont faits un an avec un
prénom
les cotes les voici anne dispose de 282
alors je vous demande vite maintenant
une décision je vais prendre gérard
jugnot oui et je vais jouer 82 80 à 2
sur gérard jugnot lourde responsabilité
gérard cinq artistes ou écrivains
français qui se sont fait un nom avec un
prénom
attention je vous écoute colette 1
raimu non non non a lancé des artistes
alain le philosophe alain le philosophe
oui avec un prénom
oh là là mais chanteur dave et se
termine
oui il y avait christofle césar
alexandre séverine stella c'est c'est eh
bien c'est terminé c'est terminé nous
allons faire les comptes 281,2 pour anne
qui bien entendu sera en notre compagnie
demain face à un autre candidat demain
cher si vous ne serez pas l'année vous
reviendrez vendredi vous pouvez disposer
de ses 160 à 2 utilisé tout de suite sur
la vente aux enchères je vous souhaite
un très très bon appétit n'oubliez pas
notre rendez vous en compagnie de
l'académie des neuf demain à 12h10 à de
me revoir
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]